[Music]
how did you guys score the coveted
Saturday night timeslot a comic-con
because usually it's safe for an
upcoming film that everybody's excited
about not that they're not excited about
your movie mistake no have you had a
chance to soak up any comic-con yet any
of you me I just got here will you have
a chance to so go down on the floor hang
out and any of you it's not tough to top
Hall H like sitting up on that panel and
feeling that energy so I don't know it'd
be very difficult to sort of top that
but it is fun to go around and check out
some stuff I did that last time we're
here you did yeah that's it 2015 was
last night how'd you get away with that
Darth Vader mask did you you went Darth
Vader was fun yeah was there ever a
moment where somebody was kind of
staring at you weirdly and you were like
woah woah woah woah
[Music]
oh really
I was speed walking everywhere so that
was also boring people but I all just
all elbows people around uh will there
be a sequel where the be a number three
a temple three I love when you guys say
that but you know deep down in your
heart I mean clearly someone has maybe
approached you or they've talked about
or they now there's an x-force movie to
think about first so well that's was
that was the next question yeah so I
think probably what we'll explore
x-force and then you know good lord
willing somewhere down the road maybe a
Deadpool three but I think x-force has
to be the priority now because we've
built team here and we got it we got a
service those guys
it's show time how cool is it that the
exports now has kind of spun off into
their own little universe how good does
that feel for you guys how the audience
loved the characters that walk away shot
at the end of the movie like people
really saw this families come together
and we did our job and yeah just curious
you know after looking at the Deadpool
poster and and tracing back and knowing
your Canadian announcer rake and the
sticky challenge and you know did he
steal what's house you like put your car
in neutral when you open the door and
then you you get down while the car you
get a friend to stare or something but
really honestly you hop out you do the
little dance and part of the dance is
you know the heart throwing up the heart
over your heart oh like that yeah and so
I thought I was like Canadian stealing
from each other are going from each
other we're gonna form a super duper
group it's time to get back on LinkedIn
how did you secure all the great cameos
for Deadpool
Brad Pitt said he would do it but only
if Brian personally delivered him a cup
of coffee from Starbucks embellished I
was told all he wants what is a cup of
coffee and I said like a franchise or
just one individual cup of coffee and
then I was told one individual cup of
coffee which is really his way of saying
like I'm doing it for nothing and it was
just a total solid nicest thing anyone
could do and I just loved it because
it's just what's more irresponsible than
taking you know one of the biggest movie
stars in the world and giving him a role
that is utterly wordless and invisible
but the exemption of three frames to
film and that that's kind of amazing but
I mean because I knew both of those guys
and I'd worked with them before but they
they would have never done a can't they
would have never done a cameo in a movie
I directed if it wasn't that there's
such a people beloved feeling for the
things that you know you guys created in
the first one that you know it was an
easy ask Celine Dion you're like an 11
we need to get you down to a five five
and a half tops just phone it in listen
this thing only goes to 11 so beat it
spider-man god I should have asked in
sync the same kind of deal again a
letter like just the power of just
asking I mean I don't know you know we
had a sort of a list and Celine was at
the top and we just thought that we
would be on you know number eight or
nine by the following week and for
whatever reason she's she said yeah I
think part of that was the song was
beautiful and it really kind of
resonated for her and she just when she
sings it you know you can't help but
just have tears fire out of your face
like a Tommy goes
[Music]
silly makes you cry you yes you lose all
the moisture in your body
[Laughter]
glad you did pick some I'm glad you
picked up a big room Anna Kendrick
apparently loved your wife and feels
like she gave me Deadpool so she should
have your wife wow she wants to take my
wife yes I guess I'm probably not the
kind of person you're normally friends
with oh you do not want to be friends
with me trust me I know a lot of guys
that would be fine with that but not me
I would like to hang on to her yeah
please let's not do that oh I can't
think of I mean she would be so well
taken care of with that although I think
you know that's got that got the goods
ya know
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]